greetings traveler to SCP Halloween
special my name is dr. Raman the undead
version of dr. Mara with a British
accent for some reason but that's not
imported as a friendly warning
the tale you are going to be hearing
today his best listens to vy headphones
with your maximum listening pleasure
so settle down get comfortable and
prepare yourselves for MTF sigma v
pumpkin punches but before we get into
this tale i'd like to take a minute to
thank my sponsor for this video
reed shadow legends forget everything
you think you know about mobile games
because one of the most ambitious RPG
projects of 2019 has just been released
introducing read shadow legends playing
red is the most immersive experience
you'll find on a smartphone that I can
only really be compared with the biggest
PC on console titles and the best part
is it's totally free an amazing
storyline awesome 3d graphics giant boss
fights PvP battles and hundreds of
champions to collect and customise over
10 million players worldwide have
already downloaded this game in less
than six months in red you have the
ability to personally customize your
champions choosing their artifacts on
creating a unique mastery build for each
one of them what I love about this game
is not everyone can find something that
they enjoy I personally I'm done for the
champion Gallic orc guy that dual wields
axes unlocking new skills abilities and
attacks for him it's pretty fun but
that's just me with over 300,000 reviews
red has an almost perfect score on the
Play Store the game is growing super
fast and highly anticipated new faction
wars feature is my life and get a new
daily login reward for the first 90 days
in the game you can find me in the game
under the neck the Volgin so what are
you waiting for go to the video
description click on the special links
and you'll get 50,000 silver and a free
epic champion as part of the new player
program to start your journey
good luck and I'll see you there
the moonlight shone on the open pumpkin
field the farm was the picture of
serenity until the piercing shout
shattered the silence move out
yelled alpha the for MTF agents
spread out across the field their
assault rifles and flashlights casting
light onto the fully grown pumpkins
why are we even here you haven't told us
what we're looking for chief question
beta aye well if I don't rightfully know
but half a dozen people going missing
here and every surrounding pumpkin farm
being torn apart during their best
season don't seem to add up right chief
responded just look for something out of
the ordinary they scavenged the field
for hours looking for anything that
could be construed as anomalous a
scarecrow that strongly resembled Delta
and extremely angry coyote and a pumpkin
that suspiciously looked like a
basketball and butter did not bounce
like one did not apply rage Julia boss
gamma finally said after a deep
inspection of a vine fine let's turn
around and head back to the site
probably some psycho axe murderer some
[ __ ] alpha turned around and began to
march in the direction of the transport
befitting given the date now we might be
able to catch the tail into the
Halloween party she had Delta and the
rest of the team turned to look at the
newest member of their team
[ __ ] hell kid nobody goes to site
parties directors always find some way
to make it about how we don't do enough
work like to see them get off their
asses and do this [ __ ] beta grumbled I
mean a party's a party right
dammit tossed out Delta interrupted by
his foot stepping on one of the smaller
pumpkins wait what the [ __ ] was check
this out pumpkins like mutated or
something
indeed the pumpkin had shattered from
Delta's steel-toed boot spilling out a
mix of various candies and sweets all
carried in a rose-colored sludge the
troops were fascinated bagged up a
sample of the Snickers for transport
alpha ordered just before a long screech
broke across the field
the members were ready in an instant
even Delta rifles raised and backs
against each other they had been
thoroughly trained in high-stakes
tactics which is why they didn't
hesitate when the first pumpkin leaped
out of the ground and rushed at them on
its spindly wooden legs three shots
later it was on the ground dropping a
blood-red
Twizzlers rope with it was that it only
to ask Delta puzzled good joke you know
you've jinxed us snarled gamma as if to
punctuate his words another shriek rang
out and the pumpkins began rising from
their vines a few swayed menacingly
while others wasted no time in charging
the squad bullets rang out like rain
each member contributing their own style
alpha methodically aimed at a lone
pumpkin and burst it and then moved to
another target beta swept his guns side
to side
shattering any pumpkin beasts that
wandered too close and showering the
battlefield with enough candy to give an
elephant a sugar rush gamma was firing
like a madman with no want for
ammunition or accuracy reveling in the
sugar lust and Delta tried to help but
whether it was the combination of his
first real ambush or the stress or
perhaps his gun jamming for some reason
he chose to resort to holding his rifle
like a bat and crushing anything that
came too close in one instance gammas
leg resulting in a swift and light kick
to the chest the team worked their way
through dozens of small pumpkin monsters
whether by shooting or smashing until
the shots silenced they were surrounded
by dozens of small fruit shaped corpses
and enough milky way's Twizzlers nerds
Hershey's sweet tarts and Pixy sticks to
open a store not to mention at least
enough apples to open a small food cart
what what the [ __ ] yelled Delta
wide-eyed and Chell shot the others
simply laughed you'll get used to it kid
weird [ __ ] comes with a job advise beta
his diatribe about reading fine print on
contracts was cut off by the ground
and rumbling they studied themselves as
a gigantic version of the pumpkins
they're just eviscerated raised itself
out of the dirt on spindly legs [ __ ] the
team opened fire but the pumpkin
abominations hide reflected the mass of
the bullets a handful preached its shell
opening ball holes from which copious
amounts of candy began to flow the Beast
traveled forward reaching out with one
of its legs and driving it directly
through gamma stomach gamma screamed
before being lifted up in the air by the
six metre tall fruit the pair looked at
each other the squads still releasing a
hail of bullets and for a moment
gamma stopped screaming then he burst
into a shower of candy Jesus yelled
alpha as he was pelted with the sugary
remains of his soldier the pumpkin used
the opportunity to dive forward and
seize beta within its grip
instantaneously exploding him into
sweets alpha and Delta backed up as the
pumpkin advanced on pushing through the
various Twizzlers and three musketeers
that half of the team and become for a
moment all was lost then alpha tore
something from his shoulder stealing
himself he charged forward and left
directly into the maw of the monster the
pumpkin rather pleased with this turn of
events appellee swallowed alpha for a
moment it stopped its advanced as it
chewed him chief
then it violently exploded as the
grenade alpha was holding detonated
within its stomach Delta shielded his
eyes as a hailstorm of candy fell upon
him but was still thrown back by the
force of the blast he sat in the field
as he was showered with enough glucose
to give 682 diabetes and watched the Sun
rise over the field surrounded by what
may or may not have been the remains of
his colleagues
you
Delta walked through the underground
security corridor leading to site 39 the
echo of his boots becoming more and more
apparent with each step his wide-eyed
face was impassive as he scanned his
keycard and pushed open the door
the Halloween party was dying down at
this point
a dozen odd researchers mingling and
holding cups of some non-alcoholic punch
as corny theme music played over the
speaker the wall across from the door
was dominated by a large banner with the
words happy Halloween along with
skeletons and pumpkins the rest of the
group finally noticed him hey Jeff
you've missed the whole party they had a
candy trade where's the rest of you guys
asked senior researcher Smith's delta's
simply kneeled over and held
I would like to give a special thank you
to permit the reclusive extrovert geum's
Sabha arbiter Sewell Tyler Shawn Justin
day Oh philia gray derp nom Curie kuma
and jayvo jack
jonathan Augusto and dr. Proctor thank
you all so much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
vulcan thank you
[Music]
you